are we good is there another season of
island coming or not i hope so dude
we need that let's let's see i gotta
maybe i should check out survivor my
parents are still obsessed with that
show
it's a that's a great show man as our
like
i always wonder who [ __ ] watches it
like nobody our age watches it besides
you
um or maybe they do and everyone just
keeps it a secret just
damn bro great at calling me out well
i've i've never heard anyone literally
no one watches that show that's our age
except who do you know that has talked
about it to you
um
steve from hr yeah literally no one
that's what i mean like no one other
shows you hear
you know you hear little you know
murmurs about it people are
talking chatting you know you see the
discourse on twitter and stuff like that
but spock actually was the one to be
like yo
i started watching survivor and i was
like dude you just saw that [ __ ] he's
like you need to watch it
and when i realized that they had gone
still
like they haven't stopped making seasons
i'm like holy [ __ ] i have to watch this
now
yeah it's pretty incredible that i've
i've seen like
six seven seasons of that show and i
haven't even scratched the surface i'm
not
like that normally is an entire series
it's game of thrones
yeah but that is what 10 of the total
episodes now
bro it's crazy too to see like because
we watched the super early season i
think it was like season six or
something
and watching the evolution of the show
to now is wild like before
it was it was like what you were talking
about which was it was super goofy like
people had like honor and respect
you know like when they introduced the
concept of like hidden immunity idols
they would put the also the brand deals
were so funny in the beginning
they would like they would like do
competitions for sears products to bring
back to their camp so it's like
they'd be in the middle of a [ __ ]
island and there's like a sears day bed
and you're like okay
they're like they had this one really
they'll be
competing in a tough obstacle course
in order to win a dicing
yeah to bring back
a black and decker leaf blower
we're on a beach man
just to remind you of home they win a
lawn mower
john deere tractor lawnmower was at
kelsey's parents place for christmas and
i wake up
super chilly wakes me up at 5 45 to go
out hell yeah
i'm taking him for a walk at 5 45 a.m
and the neighbor
is out with a leaf blower
i'm like did you just how can you more
embody
uh a dad you know 5 45 a.m and you're
out with a leaf blower for what reason
on christmas eve like sleep in
that's just when you get so old that
christmas is isn't even a day anymore
your life is just chores you just don't
[ __ ] care yeah it's just house
maintenance
house maintenance yeah exactly
yeah dude uh there's also like this one
where they
they uh it's like sponsored by sprint
and they're like oh we got tree mail and
it's like a big ass sprint logo at the
top
and they're like this challenge compete
to call your loved ones on this brand
new
sprint da da da phone you're like wow
okay
and what is it now now you don't beats
pills everywhere
no actually there's like no beats
headphones yeah
yeah yeah yeah one piece of technology
in the show is everyone gets a set of
beats headphones
all right everybody unwrap your fitbits
what
oh they're all tracking calories as they
lose tens of pounds
yeah now the show is like
self-sufficient now they don't have to
pay they don't do any of that [ __ ]
yeah um it's funny too like
when they introduce the hidden immunity
idol concept
they would get these notes and people
would read them and go
oh i got an
i i gotta know like it's like very sort
of
i want to be fair i don't want to you
know i don't want people to feel like
i'm cheating them
you know i found a hidden immunity idol
note and then you fast forward 10
seasons people like i got the idol
i'm going to tell people someone else
has it you know like it's just like
the shittiness evolution is i don't know
so you're saying the pettiness increases
oh my god dude because people watch the
show so they know
how it's played so then when they get on
the show they're just like
no holds barred like i'm gonna lie and
i'm gonna [ __ ] be shameless about it
dude
and beyonce dude and beyond that um
they like the people that are serious
about it like they
they know the rules in in ways where
you know i i think like it would escape
anyone like 20 days into a reality game
show like that
um i guess one rule is when when an
uh idol is played it goes back out into
the game the next day
immediately yeah and only some people
realize that
so they're like already on it they're
like all right that person played it i
have to go look for this thing and they
like start at like six in the morning
like i know it's here somewhere
it's like you sold me dude dude trust
trust you sold me we should do a show
where we put a bunch of
tick tock influencers and just travel
vloggers
in a house in a sick [ __ ] house okay
sickest house somewhere in like the alps
or uh
somewhere like insane right like crazy
view
sickest house you've ever seen and the
last one to post
anything about it wins uh
you know what i'm saying
i mean like the whole time they're all
just fighting the urge to like show off
no when they sign it they can't tweet
like they're going away on a show
exactly they just have to disappear yeah
that's pretty sick man damn i probably
should
edit that one out honestly
we could make that let's make it [ __ ] it
we can make that
i mean it'll be a really it'd be a
really funny um
it'd be a really funny sketch like some
girl [ __ ]
doing the talk doing the talking head oh
you want to do it for real
do it for real do it for real
oh but we filmed the whole thing right
yeah we produced this [ __ ]
it'd be so funny to watch some like
travel
influencer just being like i want to
post
so so [ __ ] bad all i think about is
posting and there's so many views here
like
i can't even describe it i'm not allowed
to legally
but it's [ __ ] insane there's an
infinity pool
in front of the [ __ ] ocean on a
mountain when you get tired
when they go they have to put their
phones like
in like some secure location like
there's like a like a 24-hour pa like
sitting in front of the phones and like
they can only tell their friends and
family that they're gone and then like
that's [ __ ] it
and it's rehab for posting basically
yeah
and they just have to sit and go oh my
god
i wanna post i wanna post on a post
they have every kind of form of
entertainment they have
uh basketball whatever
yeah oh dude and then you can do
challenges to earn
um kinds of posts you can do
like if you win a challenge that's good
you can tweet
i'm having a good day today like they
tell you exactly what you can tweet
yeah yeah or like or like uh yeah um
britney has won today's mindbender
challenge she's earned
a picture of herself reading a book in
front of the pool
oh the cover of the book in front of it
with the feet and it's just
like relaxing they're living they're
like whatever she can take a picture of
her knees
[Laughter]
oh man that'd be sick
that's funny man i'd be so good
yeah we should um i mean realistically
could we make this
i don't know
jared has won today's challenge he's
earned the
ability to promote one ventura watch
[Laughter]
god damn
god damn that's funny man
well um i mean it was your idea bro
we have to i feel like we could make
this
you know i'm down maybe we do like the
simplified version
of it where we get a bunch of people and
it's like
um it's like a short period we can hit
some people up and convince them it's a
six
hour shoot okay all right for and like
we're gonna do one challenge every hour
okay and and
first one to cave on posting
uh well like the grand prize has to be
something big oh wait wait no no hold on
hold on
okay yeah we tell them we we bring we
rent some
insane house some crazy
flex flexible house you know okay like
sometimes like miami something like that
and we okay we put
we tell them there's a 100 000 prize or
even bigger maybe i don't know quarter
million dollar prize
but they don't know what the competition
is um
and we bring them all there and if one
of them
doesn't post about it they win all the
money
they would all instantly post about it
though i know and then we say you lose
yeah then we don't have to pay anybody
yeah
and then but then
they then they all are all on the flight
back like [ __ ] man we were so close
dude how about this they could go like
this
you put them all in the house and
for every hour they don't post something
it's like a it's like a hundred bucks
150 bucks
so it's like it's like a there's like a
tangible amount like every day
oh oh and it just slowly comes off yeah
yeah
it's kind of like the the netflix one
that we were making fun of the ones not
not the circle the other one with
francesca and the
they couldn't do anything sexual
otherwise they'd lose money oh yeah yeah
but you know the island or what's that
called
yeah whatever who cares yeah the the
fake love island too hot to handle
that's what it was
no yeah but this one is just uh if you
if you have like a [ __ ] monetary
amount
on posting yeah you're like damn
oh and so they know that then they come
and they know every time they post
they lose money or they could be no no
it's like
no no it's as soon as you post you leave
with a certain amount of money
so it's like it could be like if you
don't post for one day you get this much
if you don't post for two days you get
this much three yeah
yeah i see i see i see so if they're
like damn if i just move or it could be
a big total and they know that every
time they post
depending on how flexy and douchy the
picture is they lose a certain amount of
money
so there's like some ai robot or
whatever in the house that's like like a
fake one right
that when they post they like analyze
their picture they take money off so
it's like what is the post
what is the flexing worth to you damn
some guy some dude's like dude i gotta
keep up
my brand man this is my brand i go to
places like this
so this is part of my business so i
decided to post today i lost a thousand
bucks
and there you have it guys you just
witnessed the full-on brainstorm
thank you for joining us for this
brainstorm i'm actually
pretty keen on this i'm pretty kidding
bro i think it would work better as a
sketch because you could
really i mean you could you could do so
much with the talking head interviews
yeah people just like the reasons why
they want to post so bad and show off
and yeah i just got this brand new dior
bag and it would look so
dope against this background and yeah
but also would be really funny if a kid
like noah beck came into it and like on
day one he's like
yeah i just like posted like five things
because like i got a brand deal so like
it pays for like the whole thing so like
i didn't [ __ ] care
but the house is sick and like i want to
chill so like i'm gonna stay the whole
time
i think it would be even funnier if a
dude like that
was was like just super genuine just
like i don't
yeah man i just figured i'm here i just
put my phone away and i've just been
trying to enjoy it
it's there for like five months hasn't
posted a single thing we're like [ __ ]
goddamn this guy's too
too good of a dude seven million it's
great
to be here man full advantage of this
beautiful location is just gonna soak it
up
honestly take my phone i wanted to
unplug a little bit
i hate this life anyways it's fake
[Laughter]
honestly like a forced vacation and i
need that dude
i'm like being real yeah we should um
we should explore explorer's idea i like
it we will